NEWSROOM, I'M JIM ACOSTA IN
WASHINGTON.
GOOD EVENING, IT IS NOW
MIDNIGHT IN MOROCCO.
MORE THAN 24 HOURS AFTER A
POWERFUL 6.8 MAGNITUDE
EARTHQUAKE ROCKED THE COUNTRY,
KILLING MORE THAN 2000 PEOPLE.
1400 PEOPLE ARE SAID TO BE IN
CRITICAL CONDITION AT THIS
HOUR.
HERE WE SEE A RESCUE TEAM,
PULLING A WOMAN OUT OF THE
RUBBLE.
AND, AS SEARCHES CONTINUE, THE
DEATH TOLL, WE ARE TOLD BY
OFFICIALS, IS EXPECTED TO CLIMB
EVEN HIGHER, AS THAN --
CONTINUES TO GRIND ON THEIR
MARKET.
CNN'S SAM KILEY JOINS US FROM
MARRAKECH.
SAM, WHAT'S THE LATEST THERE?
YOU ARE BACK I THINK IN THAT
LOCATION, WHERE YOU SAW PERHAPS
THE CEILING ABOVE YOU GIVING
WAY, JUST A TOUCH, HOW ARE
THINGS LOOKING WHERE YOU ARE AT?
>> WELL JIM, YOU PUT YOUR
FINGER ON WHAT EVERYBODY HERE
IS MOST OF AFRAID OF.
HERE IN THE MEDINA, AND THE OLD
CITY OF AMERICA, AN ENVIRONMENT
THAT REALLY, CERTAINLY NOT IN
LIVING MEMORY, AND CERTAINLY
FOR MANY, PEOPLE NOT EVEN IN
THE HISTORY BOOKS, HAS ANY
RECOLLECTION OF BEING WORRIED
ABOUT AN EARTHQUAKE.
HERE YOU HAVE THE DIRECT RESULT
OF IT.
THE COLLAPSE OF A --
THAT SPACE THERE IS THE NIGHT
SKY ABOVE IT, SO YOU'VE GOT A
ROOF, THE FLOOR, TO CEILINGS,
ALL COLLAPSED DOWN ONTO THE
GROUND HERE, WHERE I AM
STANDING.
AND THEN IF YOU LOOK AT THESE
BUILDINGS, WHERESE VERY
NARROW STREETS, THESE VERY VERY
AND ALL OF THESE BUILDINGS HAVE
GOT ENORMOUS CRACKS DOWN THE
SIDE, AND THE CONCERN OBVIOUSLY
IS IF ANY OF THESE CRACKS GIVE
WAY AS A RESULT OF FUTURE
TREMORS, THEN THE DEATH TOLL
HERE IN MARRAKECH, WHICH IS AT
LEAST 13, POSSIBLY HIGHER, IS
CERTAIN TO GO UP.
BUT ELSEWHERE IN THE COUNTRY,
THE SCENES HAVE BEEN ABSOLUTELY
CATASTROPHIC, JIM, WITH LARGE
NUMBERS OF VILLAGES,
PARTICULARLY IN THE FOOTHILLS
OF THE ATLAS MOUNTAINS, BEING
TOTALLY DESTROYED.
WE'VE SEEN AERIAL PICTURES OF
ENTIRE VILLAGES REDUCED TO THIS
KIND OF RUBBLE, WITH PEOPLE OF
COURSE TRAPPED BENEATH.
ALREADY IN SOME OF THE OUTLYING
VILLAGES, THERE HAVE BEEN
BURIAL CEREMONIES, IN THE
MUSLIM TRADITION, GETTING
PEOPLE --
WITHIN 24 HOURS.
ALMOST BEFORE IT'S BEEN
POSSIBLE TO GET RELIEF TO SOME
OF THESE VILLAGES, BECAUSE THE
COMMUNICATION SYSTEMS, THE
ROADS, SUCH AS THEY WERE, HAVE
BEEN CUT OR CLOSED BY
LANDSLIDES.
ENTIRE VILLAGES HAVE BEEN HIT
BY MAST LANDSLIDES, OR
THEMSELVES HAVE SLOWED DOWN THE
SIDES OF MOUNTAINS.
MANY OF THESE ENVIRONMENTS,
ONLY ACCESSIBLE BY AIR.
THE KING HERE HAS ANNOUNCED
THREE DAYS OF NATIONAL MOURNING,
THE ARMY AND OTHER SERVICES
HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN GETTING
THEIR AIRCRAFT OUT, TO TRY AND
ASSESS THE SCALE OF DEVASTATION
IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND OF COURSE, THE AFTERSHOCKS
ARE CONTINUING, OR HAVE
CONTINUED WITHIN THEAST 24
HOURS, TO SHAKE THE AREA,
PARTICULARLY IN THE ATLAS
MOUNTAINS.
MERCIFULLY, ONLY A VERY SLIGHT
AFTERSHOCKS CAN BE FELT HERE IN
MARRAKECH.
BUT IF ONE WERE TO STRIKE, THEN
IT'S PRETTY CLEAR THAT THIS
ENTIRE BUILDING COULD FOLD IN
ON ITSELF, INTO THE STREET.
AND IT'S FOR THAT REASON, JIM,
THAT A HUGE NUMBER OF AT LEAST
30% WE ARE TOLD, BY A LOT OF
HOTELIERRE, PEOPLE WHO --
THE BEAUTIFUL MANY PALACES THAT
YOU HAVE THROUGHOUT THE MEDINA
HERE, THEY'VE ALL BEEN
EVACUATED.
ALL THE RESTAURANTS CLOSED,
MANY, LARGE NUMBERS OF ORDINARY
MOROCCANS ARE NOW SLEEPING OUT
IN THE OPEN IN PARKS, OR ON
ROADS, JIM.
AND THAT IS IN ORDER TO BE AWAY
FROM ANY OF THE BUILDINGS,
WHICH WILL BE TAKING MANY, MANY
MONTHS, IF NOT YEARS, TO BRING
BACK TO THE POINT OF REPAIR, OF
WHICH THEY NO LONGER POSE A
DANGER TO THE PEOPLE THAT OWN,
OR TO LIVE IN THEM, JIM.
>> AND SAM I MEAN, YOU
ADDRESSED, IN PART, THE
QUESTION THAT I WAS JUST ABOUT
TO ASK.
WE WERE LOOKING AT SOME OF THIS
VIDEO EARLIER ON THIS EVENING,
WHERE LOOKS LIKE YOU JUST HAVE
SCORES OOPLE LIVING IN THE
STREETS.
AND, I'M JUST WONDERING, WHAT
IS IT THAT IS GOING TO BE DONE
FOR THOSE FOLKS?
I IMAGINE THAT IS WHERE THE
INTERNATIONAL RELIEF EFFORTS
ARE GOING TO BE SORELY NEEDED,
IN THE COMING DAYS.
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH,
AND WE ARE LOOKING AT SOME OF
THOSE IMAGES RIGHT NOW, THESE
FOLKS JUST SLEEPING ON THE
STREETS.
IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH THESE FOLKS
ARE GOING TO BE WITHOUT HOUSING
FOR A VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
>> I IT'S NOT YET CLEAR, I
THINK, TO THE AUTHORITIES, JIM,
THE SCALE, PARTICULARLY IN A
CITY LIKE MARRAKECH, OF THE
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING TO BE
PERMANENTLY, OR SEMI
PERMANENTLY HOMELESS.
MANY PEOPLE, AS A PRECAUTION,
ARE SIMPLY STAYING OUT OF
BUILDINGS, SLEEPING IN THE OPEN,
BECAUSE THAT WAY, FROM THEIR
VIEW, IS THE SAFEST THING TO
DO.
THE WEATHER IS NOT SO BAD, SO
THAT'S CONCEIVABLE FOR A NIGHT
OR TWO.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME OF COURSE,
THE AUTHORITIES NEED TO BE ABLE
TO SUPPLY WATER, GET THE WATER
SUPPLY GOING.
AND ABOVE ALL, MAKE SURE THAT
THESE HOMES CAN BE LIVED IN.
MANY MANY MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
HAVE BEEN SPENT OVER THE LAST
DECADES, HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS
ON RESTORING THIS ANCIENT CITY.
AND, THAT NOW HAS GOT TO START
ALL OVER AGAIN.
>> WOW.
ALL RIGHT, SAM KILEY, THEY HAVE
A LOT OF WORK AHEAD OF THEM.
THEY ARE IN MOROCCO, WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE REPORTING
YOU'VE DONE THIS EVENING, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
AND IN THE LAST HOUR, I SPOKE
WITH CARMEN MERINO, SHE'S A
HUMANITARIAN WORKER WHO WAS
VACATIONING IN MOROCCO, WHEN
THE EARTHQUAKE HIT.
AND HERE'S WHAT SHE TOLD ME.
>> I HEARD THIS FROM, PEOPLE
SCREAMING.
AND, THEIR LIGHTS WERE ALL OFF
IN SIDE THE INFRASTRUCTURE OF
THE AIRPORT, AND THE BUILDING.
AND THEN, VERY QUICKLY, I
THOUGHT AGAIN WITH THESE IMAGES,
I EXPERIENCED EARLIER THIS
YEAR.
AND, I REALIZED IT WAS AN
EARTHQUAKE.
BUT HONESTLY, I DIDN'T THINK IT
WAS THIS HARD, THIS HIGH
MAGNITUDE.
>> AND, LEARN HOW YOU CAN HELP
VICTIMS OF THE MOROCCO
EARTHQUAKE AT CNN.COM/IMPACT,
OR YOU TEXT MOROCCO TO